we're on and then this is how we start
we [ __ ] clap is that on okay um look
how we do with the [ __ ] business is
how it goes down out this [ __ ] I look I
feel like a real businessman alright um
here we go ready this episode of
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash app do you want to get paid five
dollars and also give five dollars to
charity do you want to buy and sell
Bitcoin instantly or get your paycheck
deposited right to the app well I'll
talk about the cash app and why it's the
number one finance app in the App Store
later on in the show but as for now
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now
[Music]
nice alright yeah we're here what is it
episode 61 - what happens is I have the
paper that says all the stuff on the
first first of all let me just shout out
that song is a new song well it's it's a
remix it's the mr. green remix shout out
to mr. green who has made all the
congratulations music so far the theme
music and he also has done all of the
music on all of my specials the guy's a
killer and he did the chanc smith album
which is a secret hidden gem if you know
about chang smith then you're a real
baby that's all I gotta say
so check out mr. green and his [ __ ] and
then so so what happens is this is what
I do every [ __ ] week man it says
episode whatever episode it is and then
it has the first ad that I have to read
I always read the first ad before I say
what episode it is and I read the ad ad
and I throw it that around and then
after I throw it around [ __ ] I don't
know what episode it is and then it's on
the ground and I can't move because I
got my [ __ ] headphones plugged in my
life is really hard is what I'm saying
anyway so it's episode 61 right I
haven't get rid of says it's episode 61
so that's what's up
anyway you know let's just get right
into it dude how about how I'm not the
actual guy that I play on the good
doctor so you don't have to tweet me
like I [ __ ] wronged dr. Murphy okay
because I didn't do [ __ ] know what I did
I took the money from the production
flew up to Vancouver shot it and did
whatever the writers told me okay I did
it word-for-word I didn't add [ __ ] I
didn't I didn't add [ __ ]
and people are tweeting me from the good
doctor because the last episode I did
you know I was I was first I was I was I
was Kenny I was Kenny I was uh I was uh
the good doctors friend
I was befriended the good doctor you
thought oh maybe he's the good neighbor
and uh turned out I did something shitty
to him okay now if you didn't see it
fine I'm not gonna you know I'm not
gonna ruin it if you still didn't if you
didn't check it on your [ __ ] DVR or
whatever but everyone's it's like I'm on
some some teen show we're like 12 year
olds don't know and they're like you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] how could you do this
how could you do that how could this and
that all we thought we liked you dude
people are like we thought we liked you
Chris D'Elia
but somebody wrote hey great job - I
think it's googleman is how you
pronounce her name she was a new person
on the show along with me and like we
were both been on we both start at the
same time she's like you've been doing
great Chris D'Elia not so much and I
think that he meant because I was being
shitty to Shawn I don't the guy was like
50 something and then I tweeted him back
like why not and he said no no no you're
a good actor I'm a big fan and I wrote
back No stand by it
don't [ __ ] backtrack and he wrote
this isn't going to go well from end
well for me
the driver was rolling around in my bed
like imagine being on Twitter thinking
gonna say something and nobody's gonna
see it and then the guy responds and
you're like uh-oh
Summa fave
so anyway I'm also yeah what is it Fiona
gubelman yeah she's killing it
apparently on that I think she's gonna
be in all of it actually I'm not I'm
only in a few I was only in a few
episodes I don't know if we'll be back
for Season two anyway look at the
[ __ ] bill remember the billions
[ __ ] thing due date here we go with
the billion season two or something that
show billions is there's an ad on it on
IMDB dude billions dude the most
dramatic [ __ ] still I like - we made
in front of this early on in the podcast
I like how billions still they look at
this [ __ ] they're even more dramatic
than the first photo shoot in the first
season they have [ __ ] a chandelier in
it for [ __ ] sake and berries and a
tilt and a spilled wine bottle Wow
everyone's so serious that [ __ ] looks
like a goddamn documentary oh my god
hey um anyway so yeah I'm not the guy
I'm not I'm an actor okay an actor I
stole his pizza though that was the
roughest I even though I stole his TV I
[ __ ] I stole his pizza for some
reason that was really twisted a knife
at the end of this at the end of the
show I if you find out I stole his TV
I'm ruining for you I don't give a [ __ ]
and and then I and then I go but thanks
for the pizza and I take the pizza out
of his hand the whole pie and I [ __ ]
walked back into my apartment and shut
the door on his face he's autistic a
worst person I [ __ ] stuck the knife
in that was I stole your TV by the way
huh oh thanks for the pizza this is the
what thanks for the pizza was and that's
what the thanks for the pizza was the
[ __ ] dice at the [ __ ] C rate in it
every knife they ever sold on the knife
[ __ ] QVC [ __ ] was serrated serrated
it's beautifully serrated it couldn't
just be serrated either it's beautifully
saturated look at that just look at it
everything on QVC just look at it they
show you something then say just look at
it
a beautiful ceramic angel with wings
from the artist itself they've made 20
of them look at it just look at it you
know [ __ ] look at it it's on TV just
look at it
beautiful grape flavored dildo you can
stick it on the wall it's got suction
look at it just look at it
rubber look at it they would say look at
it about anything this beautiful
twelve wronged ladder look at it yeah
it's a ladder look at it they're like a
[ __ ] deviant killer where it's like
look at it you you were you again with
the stabbing you [ __ ] stab them in
the gut and then and then they go no and
then they say look at it look at it look
at the wound look at it you're like no
you're killing me look at it look at
that beautiful wound look at it it's a
beautiful gash pumping blood spilling on
the linoleum floor look at it anyway
we're going live on my app if you don't
have my app this is what this is what we
do we shoot the podcast and we shoot it
early and then we release it later on in
the day usually on Monday sometimes
Tuesday right if you know and and you
know that because ie baby alright now
we're doing it Sunday because I got a
shoot alone together on Monday which is
a [ __ ] great show you got to check it
out and for the [ __ ] truest babies
who downloaded my app you get to see it
and be live with me hi guys you're on
the app right now I'm waving to you I
got my phone right here I'm going live
and you guys get to see it on Sunday
because you're the truest of all the
babies anyway look at that beautiful
gash it looks a little bit like a vagina
have you ever noticed a knife wound
looks like a beautiful vagina look at it
look at it look at that vagina so
[ __ ] Patrick Bateman don't just stare
at it eat it I
I was helping my parent my parent dude
my parents here's the deal man they're
like they're selling their house so
they're selling their house and every
[ __ ] thing that they it's like when
you move you know the most annoying
thing is to move because you got a pack
everything up moving sucks you got to
move it from one place to another place
you get strangers in the house packing
it all up
they steal [ __ ] naturally they still
[ __ ] and they're always called something
[ __ ] terrible like rock and roll
movers you know or like [ __ ] Teenage
Mutant Ninja movers and it's just like
so like just move my [ __ ] how about you
call your company moving don't get cute
with movers you're not baking cupcakes
he boxing up microwaves you don't need
to [ __ ] you know Dave and Mary's
[ __ ] anyway so so my point is my
point is my parents are selling their
house and they sold it they sold it and
so by the way how Jersey was it when I
referred to pizza as pie it's the most
[ __ ] that's the most Jersey thing you
could do
hey you got a pizza pie hey you want a
slice of pie yeah slice of pie yeah is
it Apple egg [ __ ] out of here apple pie
[ __ ] America ah not do it hey hey
it's a [ __ ] pizza pie anyway my
parents are moving and it took like
[ __ ] it took like um what do you call
it uh they're like yeah come down to the
beach we got stuff Chris you got a big
car you know it's like you get the big
car and everyone's [ __ ] asking you to
do you get a big car could you help us
so I went down last week and I posted
some video of it on Instagram and then I
went down [ __ ] again this week and
they're like there's still some there's
still some stuff we don't want the
movers to take and I'm like really is it
that or is it just you want to see see
[ __ ] me and my brother again in the
house before that you [ __ ] Lee
because dad he sentimentally [ __ ] and so
you know so I went down there and I did
it and why did I bring this story up
though I brought it up for a reason
oh yeah because I [ __ ] love [ __ ]
around man dude well like I said this
[ __ ] in the first or second episode
I'm down for a silly goose time and
that's it
and you could quote me on that
[ __ ] I'm down for a silly goose
time and that's it so so anyway I will
Iowa they were packing up and every time
I would like do one thing like a move
one thing into a car I go I just got I
just go like this I go all right well
like that was the last thing and we were
about to leave all right all right well
guys that was [ __ ] man and they would be
like Chris stop and I'm 37 but every
time I did one thing like I would put
one thing in their car and be like well
that about does it
the whole car would be [ __ ] empty and
we're not even ready and they would be
so and they'd laugh at first and then
they'd be like alright come on you know
stop and then I would just to that I'd
be like well and then they'd get mad and
then it became funny again you know
which was the best because then my
brother was like two more two more
like such a little brother [ __ ] my
brother's such a little brother dude do
more do it more alright guys well that's
about it [ __ ] I guess we got to go well
it was great moving so anyway look at it
yeah those good so what so here's
another thing too by the way there's the
first time ever printed out some notes
I'm cute bro I'm [ __ ] you I printed
out notes this time now [ __ ] cute
took 61 episodes to [ __ ] get it
together and I got [ __ ] 6 notes dude
that's how we do it and I already hit
good doctor tweets so we got [ __ ] 1 2
3 4 more notes so I had one note down
let's talk about this one now oh let me
tell you something man I go to a gym and
it's cool and it's all good and it's all
[ __ ] good and dude and I don't say
this a lot ok but it's all good in the
hood all right it's all [ __ ] gravy
and I don't say either of those things
ever I don't say it's all good and I
don't I don't see it's all good in hood
and I don't say it's it's all gravy but
let me tell you something it's all good
hood it's all gravy all right but dude I
got the I got the the VIP I paid for the
[ __ ] VIP locker room dude this
[ __ ] [ __ ] is Narnia the regular
the regular locker room is so crowded
it's like a [ __ ] Japanese subway it's
SSO crowded there are guys that walk
around with their [ __ ] and balls out no
I don't give a [ __ ] about that I don't
care about that that's fine but three
guys that's limit okay
not everybody also some of them are real
old and some of them are out of shape
whatever it's not it's as clean as they
make it the gym I go to is nice and
clean it's as clean you got a lot of
guys in there naked showering and [ __ ]
there's gonna be some athlete's foot out
per outbreak okay
now every now and then I got the VIP
[ __ ] bro it's [ __ ] unbelievable first
of all you use an eye scanner to open
the [ __ ] unlock the door
hey dude what are we in a [ __ ] Tom
Cruise movie we're a quick worst Keanu
okay and then it goes become and then
you conch and then it invites you when
you go in dude it's like Narnia it's
like you entered the [ __ ] wardrobe or
whatever and they give you waters they
got fruit there they got a lounge area
in the VIP they got TVs they got [ __ ]
nobody's ever in there and the guy
looked at me at the end of the [ __ ]
run-through or whatever call it whatever
he owned me the [ __ ] and he was like and
here's your laundry bag and I was like
huh and he says well you put your
laundry in here and then when you come
back tomorrow your laundry will be ready
huh dude you're gonna do my laundry yeah
awesome the gift [ __ ] [ __ ] does my
laundry anyway hey live babies that's
what you're getting
thank you very much for do it down this
out I'm gonna definitely do this again I
had fun but check out the rest of the
podcast
what do you call it tomorrow so I'm
going offline here but BAM there did it
all right that's what's up yeah so
anyway but it's awesome dude they have
this [ __ ] it's it's great I loved it
I loved being [ __ ] man I like I like
working out because it [ __ ] keeps me
sane dude here's the thing people didn't
really like I I found this out recently
people didn't really like lift hardcore
wait until like recently like that's a
newish thing and those people are
finally getting old like Arnold and [ __ ]
and like a little bit before Arnold but
like remember those [ __ ] fake strong
guys that were like in the early 1900s
that really they weren't even just
strong they just puffed their chests out
- no I'm talking about and they were
just like you were like if they just
slouch they look like a dad but like
they would just and they just have like
that the [ __ ] barbells with the big
ass fears on the side like which is bad
cuz it's gonna roll away when you put it
down you know anyway I like how [ __ ]
Ivan get rid of put in the thing old
timey strongman and everything came up
that's hilarious
but like those guys but like the weight
lifters that's like a generally new
thing like people weren't lifting
weights in the [ __ ] you know anytime
anyone talked like this like back then
when people like dirty is [ __ ] and like
only wore brown and they were like my
god like they didn't lift the weights
they were just [ __ ] they walked
everywhere and that's why they kept trim
because they were like I don't horse
every now and then but they'd have to do
everything themselves you know there was
no Wi-Fi so they'd go out and play but
but like everyone's getting older and
like all that [ __ ] weightlifting like
I feel like in a hundred years that's
why all this [ __ ] like plyometrics and
uh plyometrics that was called Plato
metrics that [ __ ] will you stand on
the ball and you just try to balance and
[ __ ] plyo exercising whatever they call
it plyo but like and then and and
like HIIT workout or high intensity
training hit or hit interval height is
he energy I don't know what the [ __ ] it
stands for anyway like that stuff seems
to be and then people swear on CrossFit
but hey CrossFit hey so many injuries so
many goddamn injuries hey lift up this
[ __ ] keg you know hey what we're
doing now is we're doing keg squats huh
yeah this keg is filled it's about how
much is away we don't even know just
[ __ ] lift it lift it and then and
then push it above your head and then
drop it down real [ __ ] hard and if
someone's in the way they'll get killed
and by the way we're [ __ ] up your
back
CrossFit dude how many people have done
CrossFit for like four months and
they're like okay well yeah my legs all
[ __ ]
but that's why that [ __ ] like like I
feel like Orangetheory or whatever like
those are pretty good but like this [ __ ]
were they [ __ ] what's up with that
big-ass tire that every gym has now
especially the CrossFit gym what what
[ __ ] work first of all where do you
get it you know I feel like those are
just made in Sacramento and anytime you
need one they truck them out from
Sacramento this is the most Sacramento
Sacramento we asked [ __ ] is it those
big-ass [ __ ] tires that are taller
than you what's it for
where do you put it on what wheels does
it go huh the larger it's for like
[ __ ] cranes I guess and you got to
jump on it and push it and then flip it
over and you only unit by the way you
never see a fat guy do that ever
it's always the most ripped of
[ __ ] flipping a big-ass tire
back and forth or literally
strongest woman you've ever seen in your
life and then she turns around and she
says okay tires flipped anyway did you
need this on a crane or something let's
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] you though
turn around anyone need some wheels that
are way too big
yeah but I'm now so I'm in that [ __ ]
VIP locker room do it and there's no
turning back there's no turning back
dude I took a shower at the gym the
other day I never did that they do you
walk in you have your shirt and pants
and underwear you walk in you change cuz
they have your laundry and then you work
out you go back in you shower put on
your clothes it came in you leave it's
like you're shopping you're not [ __ ]
working out you don't leave a sweaty
mess you leave nice I want to know two
things okay in the world I've thought
about this all week two things I want to
know if I had a time machine okay to go
back in time now realistically I would
go back and hang out with Tupac or go
back you know go back and with Tupac or
go back to the 80s and just sit in the
back of the Comedy Store and watch right
you know I it's kind of odd when people
say [ __ ] like I'd go back and see the
dinosaurs like I get that but when
people are like but to me I'd want to go
back not that far if I had a time
machine because I'd want to see how it
was just before me or like stuff that
affects me like like stand-up or like
Tupac is my favorite artist ever so like
I'd want to go back and see what he's
all about and be during that time even
though I was 10 when he was rapping but
like and and and 12 and 13 and he died
when I was I think 16 but but to go back
and to like see him or something
like that affects me more than you you
know then whatever the [ __ ] going back
to meet Napoleon even though I would
want to do that - that'd be crazy see
I'm sure he wasn't [ __ ] and see how
[ __ ] he was you know Napoleon was so
[ __ ] you know he was just like I would
was he French right so I need to cook at
the hello world you know and he was just
so [ __ ] and you know you know like when
girls when he had sex with girls he was
like was that the best one you've ever
had and she was like it we we we we I
mean that you know and he's so short but
he was like best father you're ever here
and she's like you we we we and he's
like I never know because he's this tall
right you know he when he got mad he
went like this and and anyway
well what oh yeah that's what I would do
for real is go back to see Tupac well go
back to the part we'll go back into the
back of the room and - can I go to the
back of the mother comedy store and
watch this guy's like Richard Pryor
Robin Williams David Letterman [ __ ]
Sam Kinison all those [ __ ]
right um or even Dave Chappelle coming
up you know what I mean like guys like
that Chris Rock you know what I mean
like anyway George Carlin see those guys
but I wanted I would go back I would
also see if I got it like a time machine
and if I could only use it a few times
I'd see if I could talk to the
technician and tack on one more go back
in time so I could [ __ ] murder the
guy right before he coined the term
Mickey D's you know whoever [ __ ]
thought that was cute whoever whoever
thought I don't know if it was somebody
that worked for McDonald's or if it was
just somebody that started calling it
Mickey D's he was like the fun guy in
the [ __ ] in the in the class or the
[ __ ] camp or like the workplace the
shortened version of McDonald's
even urban dictionary calls it the
shortened version of McDonald's even
though you're not saving any syllables I
agree
dude if you if you have if you have like
even urban dictionary [ __ ] hates it
like even if you have if you're trying
to abbreviate something and it's not
abbreviated you're still saying the same
amount of syllables huckett gunk
turnaround mints idea dude
Mickey D's to think that that's cute
and to think that that's funny and to
think that that's humorous if you were a
housewife it had to be a housewife it
had to be a woman with kids that was
bored out of her [ __ ] mind cuz I mean
it was a long time ago it's been Mickey
D's ever since I was born I think maybe
it was the branding [ __ ] yeah you know
Mickey D's is a fun way to say it I'll
[ __ ] if you say Mickey D's hey II CUDA
you are yar I just imagine take it like
do people there's also a [ __ ] on
Sunset Boulevard there's McDonald's and
then next to it there's a new show
coming out called like Mick mafia or
something and it's like directly across
from McDonald's and every time I Drive
by I'm like they put this [ __ ]
billboard Mafia right next to McDonald's
it's so [ __ ] and you know what that is
Mick annoying that's Mick nyan put the
Billboard a little bit down further
thanks a.m. see also Mick mafia dude hey
Cyrus oh hey where was Mick mafia oh
really zombie see and the [ __ ] although
that guy's a really good actor the lead
in that [ __ ] Mick mafia he's [ __ ]
really good I love that guy what's his
name James Norton
yeah he's [ __ ] good he was in I think
he was in the fall was he in the fall
what was he in no yeah it was a little
earlier than that black mirror it wasn't
something I saw Doctor Who
I don't know anyway yeah dude don't say
Mickey D's you don't do that if you see
another baby doing that you [ __ ]
correct that [ __ ]
how about that [ __ ] thing with the
Doctor Who guy when they were talking
about how they were trying to [ __ ]
get him to give up his money did you see
that they were trying to so people found
out that I think it's the Queen the
movie to show the Queen that the the Lee
the actress on the Queen got paid less
than the guy in the Queen and they were
like oh it's not right and it's she's a
bigger part she's the lead it's about
her it's the Queen but the guy on the
Queen is more famous he played doctor
who like for [ __ ] a few years or
something like that so people are like I
mean the left a lot of the [ __ ] or
not I mean the left just [ __ ]
snowflakes are like oh well that's not
fair he should donate his discrepancy of
money towards the [ __ ] if he was a
good guy he'd donate his money are you
[ __ ] kidding me let me tell you
something man
get your [ __ ] money it's not
fair out there get your money dude get
your money Mark Wahlberg everyone
pressured him dude it was in his deal
that way dude it may not be fair but
that's not how you correct it is
pressuring some guy to [ __ ] push his
money into some oh dude and then if he
didn't he would have been like people
would have thought it was a piece of
[ __ ] and not to go see his movies
that's wrong dude that's [ __ ] wrong
you can't pressure somebody into [ __ ]
giving up their money that they've
worked oh okay II communist this is what
America is based on work the hardest get
paid the most now I got a question for
you eat communists what's the [ __ ]
incentive that's not how you fix it is
starting at the top and trying to fix it
at the top that is not how you [ __ ]
fix anything is going to the top and
trying to [ __ ] band-aid it up you
gotta [ __ ] start at the bottom dude
make more opportunities for the [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] I don't know I
certainly don't know but I know you
don't start at the top and say hey Mark
Wahlberg
by the way give your money up what you
start way before that you start at the
bottom people just want to fix it and
they want to surface they're like that
[ __ ] that couch [ __ ] on the QVC the
leather couch where they're like hey you
don't have to fix your couch just
[ __ ] paint this plaster over it we
got it in all colors it's still a
[ __ ] rip in it your piece of [ __ ]
oh dude I wish it'd happen to me
hey Chris D'Elia you got to donate your
money I go like this I make a video I
look right into the video and I say hey
dude guess what I'm doing
stacking my chips dude this is my
[ __ ] money I worked for give it up
for something that you deem giving it up
worthy I got a [ __ ] I got something
to tell you I got something to [ __ ]
tell you instead I got something
sincerely to tell you instead I got
something [ __ ] way to his sincerely
to tell you hmm got something way
[ __ ] too serious to tell you okay
can't find it so got something sincerely
to tell you
how about that
hey how about how we knit all I did make
the right there hey Chris donate your
money to a cause we deem or else your
careers over I can't hear you
all of the windows are up invite
helicopter nobody's gonna get mad at
that I don't give a [ __ ] it's a comedy
podcast anyway dude uh here we go quip
that's what's up if you're a person with
a mouth which you are unless your
counter Eve's in that one scene in the
matrix it's likely that you don't brush
your teeth for a full two minutes change
your brush on time or brush twice a day
quip gets that so they've designed the
perfect electric toothbrush quip is the
new electric toothbrush that packs just
the right amount of vibrations into a
slimmer design at a fraction of the cost
of bulkier traditional electric brushes
now were there too many words in that
sentence yes but that's the copy most
toothbrushes don't get named one of Time
Magazine's best inventions of the year
but quip did find out yourself why it's
a great toothbrush I use it I only use
it I bring it on the road and I use it
looks like it's designed by Apple is
very cool and it's sleek and it's slim
and I'm cool and I brush my teeth and
I'm very cool when I do it okay
quip starts at just $25 and right now
when you go to get quip comm / Congrats
to get you first you can go to get quip
comm sauce Congrats to get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush
that's your first refill pack that's
your first refill pack free at get quip
comm / Congrats spelled GE t q UI p.com
/ Congrats toss that paper to the side
cuz we're done square cash square cash
if you haven't heard we are switching to
the cash app it's the simplest way to
pay people back friends family you know
movers shaker
big moneymakers and I didn't even mean
to rhyme anyone you can pet him back you
resetting receiving money money is
totally free and fast and most payments
could be deposited directly in your bank
account in just in mere seconds from
like like that fast right and it's it's
it's great because a lot of people are
starting to use more and more people
trying to use it and it's just it's just
easier dude I use it for a lot of stuff
cash up unless you do even more than
that though now you can buy and sell
Bitcoin instantly get your paycheck
deposited right to the app pull money
out of the ATM with a free custom cash
card use it to spend anywhere you like
you're not gonna find a more useful
finance app out there sincerely and
that's coming from me download the cash
app and $5 goes to you and $5 goes to x
up Legal Defense Fund the Legal Defense
Fund is is a great thing because we here
at congratulations believe in the x up
cause and even get rid of does and so
does one fire
download the free cash app for iOS or
android now so yeah so that's that's
good do you guys see oh so that doesn't
the two things I was thinking of all
week
the Mickey D's thing and then also there
here's a fundament the fundamental
difference between me and somebody all
right if I'm at a restaurant a nice
restaurant which I don't go to but man
once every few months if that really
some restaurants do this thing where
they'll be like hi how are you doing can
I take your can I take your drink order
and you're like I'm not yeah I'll have a
you know whatever club soda coca-cola
wine beer whatever the [ __ ] and they'll
be like okay I'll come right back to
take your order and then you come back
and I'm like hi would you like to take
your order
I would like to take your order yeah I
get the [ __ ] squash ravioli and the
[ __ ] salmon or whatever the [ __ ] and
I'm like okay now would you like to
order dessert because
the desert takes 35 minutes to make and
if you want the desert you can order it
later but it'll take 35 minutes to make
so if you know you want the desert now
in order to the desert now this way
it'll be ready for you after you my
answer is always no because how the [ __ ]
do I know if I'm gonna want desert
I didn't even eat the meal yet who knows
how much I'm gonna eat
who knows if I am gonna have a hankering
for some sweet [ __ ] if you say yes at
that moment me sometimes they're like hi
welcome to [ __ ] wherever what do you
know if you want dessert yet before we
get things started off and you're like
huh can you take my drink order they do
that the valet you park and they're like
hey I think it here's ticket it's gonna
be $10 when you come back do you know if
you want dessert I tell them inside it
takes 35 minutes to make the coin while
you're getting ready you putting on your
[ __ ] button-down hello hi this is the
really nice restaurant you're coming to
are you going to want dessert can I
figure it out when I get there it's like
who the [ __ ] no no no no here's the deal
you don't have dessert that takes 35
minutes to make you have dessert that
takes ten minutes to make forever no
matter what restaurant you're in and and
those are the desserts you have this way
I can order if I want after I got there
me
that's a [ __ ] legit rule if you're
the kind of person that's like oh yeah
you know what that's such a chick thing
to do I bet oh it sounds good like you
just like the sound of it like chicks
love ideas you're not I'm talking about
chicks love to say [ __ ] like to their
boyfriends where they're like you know
what we should fix up an old car and
you're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking all really let's let me talk
let's talk about that tomorrow and
they'll be like and then you'll be like
hey do you want to fix up that you want
to get she look up old cars I don't know
you know I was just like I mean yeah we
could do it but like
but dudu I'm sure they're due to do that
[ __ ] to just like yeah I'll get the
desert yeah let's order that now and
then you eat me [ __ ] stuff it up and
then you're like oh I don't know if I
want the desert anymore nah nah dude
you're there's a fundamental difference
between me and you if you order that
[ __ ] desert a hundred percent before
ordering dessert before yeah you order
your meal will you like a [ __ ] the
Precog of restaurants what is this
Minority Report restaurant edition let
me check with the cogs and then there's
three ball the white chicks in a [ __ ]
of that of disc disgusting placenta
fluid and they're just like order it and
they're like [ __ ] we got over the desert
now it has to be ordered okay order it
there that [ __ ] there at tau on
unfuckin Cahuenga order it the one in
Vegas or the one in Cahuenga in
Hollywood through it the what which one
cogs ask the cogs he's in Vegas scratch
that Vegas order it do the cogs agree
yes like come on desert takes you know
what have the desert ready how about
that don't even make the desert have
cookies ice cream and some [ __ ]
Manila fingers or whatever the [ __ ]
they're called that's it have a brownie
and put some raspberry sauce dude a
[ __ ] hate when people put raspberry
sauce on desserts it [ __ ] it right up
congratulations man congratu the [ __ ]
lations oh did you put raspberry sauce
on my dessert guess what you did you
[ __ ] my [ __ ] right up you did you
might as well wiped your [ __ ] anus on
my brownie dude I we used to be married
okay
and I was married to I don't know if
it's a Mormon thing but I was married to
this girl and her family was Mormon and
dude her family was the best okay
they put [ __ ] raspberry sauce on
everything I could imagine dude they put
it on salad they'd be like it's a
raspberry vinaigrette
okay now would you like [ __ ] we made
quick croissants these by the way - you
said quoi song go to France that's it
that's it very simple I'm not mad
just go to France do you say croissant
congratulations you've got land here
keep it did you say quest on look I'm
not even mad go to France just go to
France no hard feelings
take a flight take it take it take the
next trip take the next flight to France
have as many questions as you want okay
but did she
they'd be like raspberry everything
raspberry no chocolate nothing no
[ __ ] apricot [ __ ] no Kiwi nothing
dude raspberry sauce the day is long no
[ __ ] there'll be raspberry sauce on
[ __ ] like turkey and [ __ ] it was
weird as [ __ ] they'd have raspberry
sauce on like you'd be like go outside
here's your [ __ ] jacket make sure to
dip it in some raspberry sauce it's cold
out there and you didn't even think
about it you're just like okay anyway
what outside cold the [ __ ] tasting like
raspberry oh what's going on well I got
raspberry on me they just be sitting
there mm-hmm
it was weird as [ __ ] dude I don't know
if that's a Mormon thing or what it
sounds like it would be a Mormon thing
though raspberry sauce like that's how
they get their kicks you know because
they can't drink caffeine they're just
like maybe that's how they get you dude
try some raspberry sauce would you like
would you like some raspberry sauce and
you're like I don't know no way it's
very good anyway it's here if you'd like
we use it for dipping and you're like uh
I guess I'll try it man everyone's so
nice I mean maybe it's good and you just
eat it and become a little blonder every
time you eat it
and God and he checking them after a few
meals you check-in you're like what the
[ __ ] and you look you like I'm not going
gray and you look closer and you just
really look it's blonde and you're like
what tough and you go what the and all
of a sudden you catch yourself saying
what the Frick
I mean wait what what the freaking heck
is going on and you're like excuse me
Melinda come in here do you see this and
then she just says oh my and like what
you're going blonde and she's like what
the Frick and you're like yeah is it
what's been different in our lives and
she's like I'm I can't they get anything
I mean we kind of just how long has it
been getting how long you been going
gray I don't know four or five weeks a
month you know she's like what the only
thing that's new in our life is we're
friends with the Swensons and as I can't
but but what was that have to do with
anything can't happen I'm getting grey
or anything I'm getting blonde cuz of
the Swensons she's like I don't freaking
know I don't actually don't flippin know
she says you know I don't know and they
just like throwing away your from
coca-cola for some no reason I don't
know what's going on and then all of a
sudden you're you're like one day like
do you think it's the flipping raspberry
sauce and by then it's too late
you're a part of the Jesus Christ Church
of Latter day Saints hey have more words
in your church title by the way Jesus
Christ latter-day saints of Church of
Jesus Christ ings the pedestrian
Church Saint Henry of congratulations
latter-day saints Athan what how [ __ ]
boring
is Church make it more exciting and I
know people are gonna say [ __ ] like well
you just haven't been to the right
Church and to those people I go like
this no instead of that you're a boring
person it's okay to go to church and
it's great and it's but don't tell me
it's fun it is boring and that's why
it's Church because you're there to
worship not celebrate slam John now that
is a am i a waiter at Denny's cuz I
served you a hot piping plate of Denny's
Grand Slam breakfast it's for worship
that's why some religions get on their
[ __ ] knees and do it because it's
supposed to hurt your knees because you
worshipping they don't put you in a
[ __ ] lazy boy do they that church
isn't fun it's not spouse not being
sacrilegious it's not suppose flocking
it up dude anyway what do you want to do
[ __ ] it elders or you want to do
[Music]
elders or what can we do here let me
look at the Instagram see if I got some
[ __ ] Instagram [ __ ]
and do I have
wack Chua Lee you know what I Wow I just
remembered what happened was [ __ ] Ben
Affleck's back tattoo you saw that dude
okay look I actually I like Ben Affleck
I think he's in cool movie
I [ __ ] I think he's good he's good
director
i I [ __ ] liked him as Batman I know I
think that's the unpopular opinion but I
thought he was cool as [ __ ] as Batman he
looks the part he's [ __ ] got cool gray
hairs that's how I think Bruce Wayne
should be
I liked him as Batman okay go [ __ ]
yourself but like and that back tattoo
look who gives a [ __ ] if a back tattoo
is what someone else likes you gotta
like it fine the funniest [ __ ] though
was they were making fun of it and he
said no it's just for a movie and then
years later they got a picture with him
with the tattoo on I don't quite get
what is that part on the bottom under
the wing that's not attached to the
Phoenix also to get yeah what is that
this is like a dildo but why is it not
connected there's word breaks in it yeah
that is weird but it's just odd that he
got that tattoo that's so big but maybe
he did get it for the movie and then
just decided to keep it but the fact
that he said it was just and that's that
was cool but the fact that it dude I
don't understand this dude what's it for
somebody to say yo that back tattoo
sucks to me I go I go I go in your face
I closed the distance and I say bro this
back tattoo is the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't know what you if that it dude
guess what I happen to think that back
tattoo I happen to think I don't I I
think it's ugly okay that's my opinion
if if Ben Affleck came out with a video
that said hey you know I've been I've
been hearing about this [ __ ] about my
back tattoo I know a lot of you guys
don't like a back tattoo but I just got
one thing to say to you guys
[Music]
and then he takes his shirt off in the
vlog turns around and does a [ __ ] and
points down to it with two thumbs over
his shoulders and then just [ __ ] and
there's a little activation with his
hips dude and then he looks in the
camera it says guess what I have [ __ ]
some of your wives probably and then he
goes like and then he goes like this and
then goes Good Will Hunting and then
[ __ ] it's over and then the next time
you see him it's wrapped around he got
it [ __ ] more it wrapped around his
front - no [ __ ] Ben Affleck right
then would skyrocket - my favorite actor
of all time talent wise that's how hard
I would like that not just favorite
actor talent wise I'd be like he's the
most talented actor over Daniel
day-lewis Christian Bale [ __ ] the guy
who played them in the movie darkest
hour Gary Oldman he's better than all
those [ __ ] dude I watched the
darkest hour or I tried to hey that's
all I'll say about that you figure out
if I liked it or not buy this hey hey
hey could we put more shades of brown in
that movie hey could you put more
bulbous noses in that movie Oh
could you just Oh a could I make sure
could we make sure I can't hear a word
coming out of Gary Oldman's mouth
I get it good acting and I dude I it was
he's good gary oldman is honestly one of
the best actors of this generation if
you don't think so
[ __ ] you straight up but he is not
better than Ben Affleck if he gets a
[ __ ] wrapped around Phoenix tattoo
all over his tummy - there's no way
talent-wise Ben Affleck is better that's
how it goes um I mean I don't understand
why people don't see that's how Trump
that's how Trump became president you're
damn right I'm gonna do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] when it when we said
you know what I knew he was gonna be
President
when he said we're gonna build a wall
and you said everyone said no you're not
and he said oh yeah
as a matter of fact I'm gonna get Mexico
to pay for it you know that I was that
meme of that [ __ ] of the dudes in the
playground that are like oh I was that
meme when he said that one and I knew it
wasn't gonna happen it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter when he did that [ __ ]
dude when Trump was like yeah I'm and
guess who's gonna pay for it Mexico and
then the Mexican president was like no
we're not and then and then Trump girls
I guess oh that's funny and then he
should to get a wall tattoo on his back
turned around and [ __ ] put his thumbs
up of his shoulders pointing to the wall
and [ __ ] wrapped that [ __ ]
round his fat ass white tummy [ __ ] yo
[ __ ] i'm donald trump head donald trump
your orange obviously don't be orange
why does anybody ever talk about
anything about Donald Trump besides
fact that he's [ __ ] orange I know
that's a big thing out there we all know
but why on earth does anybody ever talk
about anything else besides the fact
that our president is a new race oh it's
cool but you're drawn by Matt Groening
you Donald Simpson dude what a how [ __ ]
is it to fake tan as a guy as a woman I
get it
there's a [ __ ] whole industry for
looking good with women there is less of
an industry for a minute also the guys
who do it aren't even in that industry
you're trying to be a [ __ ]
businessman you don't need to fake tan
what the [ __ ] he don't what he don't
wrap that tattoo around you if people
talk [ __ ] man all right we got an elder
dude we got a new elder and he is I
really liked this phase all at Faizal
FAI s Excel I guess he's extra-large and
this is why because he made this there
we go this is why he's our elder
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll tweet the link for the rest of it
he [ __ ] that remix is awesome it
sounds like he's rapping on that beat I
always thought to whenever Tupac came
out with like other music after he died
and they tried to remix it always
sounded like you could tell that's like
you don't you can barely tell maybe I'm
biased I just said it sounds great the
way he [ __ ] did it and I first heard
that I was like oh [ __ ] you know he's my
favorite and that was [ __ ] awesome to
do that to the congratulations beat but
I love how Tupac laughs like you [ __ ]
pinched your titties you know what I
mean ah yeah just move you can't yeah
gave you a titty twister anyway phase
out we will DM you we will damn you with
your with the info so make sure you
follow us you probably do but you're you
did your pit you pending your
certificate cool coolin coolin coolin
babies let's take some questions here
Luke Edwards at Lukey underscore the
underscore Pugh Lukey the poo you know
what's coming
hey change it um not really gaming the
system here but at Chris D'Elia what are
your thoughts on you know it turns out
you are game in the system because you
did it on to today which or wait no oh
no this was yesterday even Wow yeah you
weren't really gaming the system but
it's all good
what are your thoughts on people who
call themselves a snack yeah well if you
call yourself a snack you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you call Bay a snack or
whatever they would say then that's ok
cuz it's like giving them a compliment
if you call yourself a snack you deserve
to be a snack for lions
ok you deserve to be eaten you yeah and
it's not cool it's definitely definitely
not cool look at the pool
it's funny Sophia gee at self Giardini
Giardini er do you need Gherardini I
don't know what do you think about the
British royal family and humps and how
so many people are invested in it is it
the 1500s no ok who gives a [ __ ] yeah I
don't know about that I actually don't
know I guess that's a fine question I
don't know is that something that is
only that should only be in the fifteen
hundreds I guess I don't know me I don't
know enough about it just to say if it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] or not but yeah that's
it I don't know
you know what you stumped me on Twitter
questions I even get rid of sent me a
stumper yeah I think we could wrap
things up here that was a fun one man
and I'm I had a good time and I am so
this is gonna come out on Monday so
which is today you guys wink-wink even
though I did it yesterday I have all my
dates coming up if they're not up now
they will be up by the end of the day
because Monday is the day we were going
to we were going to do it but he so one
fighter couple on fire is gonna add them
I am announcing all of the the second
leg and there and there are a lot of
cities on this coming up
you know Red Bank Red Bank New Jersey
Maine there's one in Maine Portland
Maine I think Portland Maine and then
other places
oh oh I got him right here it's right
here Eugene Oregon Sacramento California
Red Bank New Jersey Wilmington Delaware
ready Reading Pennsylvania Tulsa
Oklahoma Midwest City Oklahoma Dallas
Texas Portland Maine Hampton Beach North
New Hampshire North Hampshire
Mashantucket Connecticut which is my
least favorite place to perform because
it's the casino and I [ __ ] hate it
Houston Texas Wichita kale what's that
would you do that did you do it wrong ko
what is it ka one fire dude he's not
here and put Wichita cones this [ __ ]
[ __ ] off bro this guy [ __ ] isn't ears
I effects all in Wichita cones it so
we're coming for you Wichita Kansas and
then Kansas City Missouri Lincoln
Nebraska renown of Reno Nevada and Las
Vegas Nevada Las Vegas Nevada that's the
second leg leg that's the second leg now
everybody [ __ ] relax I'm doing a
third leg and that leg is gonna be bonks
it's gonna be bonks it's gonna be
bonkers I'm gonna do all the East Coast
dates the [ __ ] like we'll be in you know
New York they'll be they'll be New York
to Boston they'll be all the [ __ ] there
so and it oh yeah probably add probably
added Lana and even Phoenix I think but
yet so there's a lot coming out I know
Phoenix isn't on the East Coast okay so
you need to correct me but Boston in New
York and Atlanta Kanye's so that's
what's up those are the cities I'm doing
on the second leg go get your tickets I
think they're available presale and
they'll be sold
for across the board across the board
later on in the week you guys are
[ __ ] awesome subscribe to the YouTube
channel please we always have a hundred
thousand subscribers so see if we can
get there
download the Chris D'Elia app for iOS or
Android and you know what you can do I'm
gonna definitely go live on that every
now and then for the babies subscribe
rate and review the show on the app you
got it help me out and do all this [ __ ]
it really helps the app it helps the
numbers and it helps grow it and that's
what we're trying to do because we're
trying to get to this [ __ ] log cabin
video episodes go up Tuesday's or wend
at Wednesday's you watch my specials
share up man tell people about everybody
tell one person about man on fire that's
your [ __ ] homework as babies I'll be
on more episodes of the load together
coming up for the second season I'm
shooting that today and thank you for
listening
[Music]